[Music]
Neil welcome back to the GSB well thank
you for having me Shannon hello
everybody it's great to be back it's
always super exciting to be although I
was not on this campus I was at that
very old campus uh but it's great to be
uh on site with all of you well it's
great to have an Alum on this stage
who's been in our shoes before and when
I Was preparing for this interview I did
the first thing we always do I looked
you up on YouTube and I want to show one
of my favorite videos that I found uh oh
let see what this
is Neil Mohan is the most mysterious man
on YouTube he's a new CEO and people
don't know what to think about him so I
decided to invite him to a music
festival to get a Vibe check on him and
he said yes I decided to put my best
foot forward and get commemorative best
friend t-shirts made nice Neil and I had
lunch together and he bought me my
favorite food Neil and I made our own
secret handshake Neil and I unsubscribed
for Mr Beast Neil gave me a piggyback
ride when my feet started to hurt I
didn't even ask Neil and I signed a
legally binding agreement that
prioritizes my videos over everyone
else's videos on the YouTube
algorithm need you to stop overall I
give Neil a 9.5 out of
10 oh my
God I I didn't realize that when I took
over the CEO gig a big part of my job
would be being a straight man for our
for a lot of YouTubers out there but the
other the funny thing about that uh that
video was you know I've you know I do
like you know lots of various press
interviews and this and that and um I
have a 15-year-old and his friends
couldn't have cared less about any of
that stuff but when I was in that short
with a act that was like I basically hit
the big leagues with the with the
15-year-old set so that was pretty
exciting that's great and I mean a 9.5
creators are a tough crowd I know I know
uh we have so much to cover today from
creators to AI to your personal
leadership uh and we'll get to all of it
but I want to start at the beginning you
were born in Indiana and spent the
second part of your childhood in India
how did those early experiences
influence you um it's a great question
um and uh you know just by way of
background my my story like the you know
I and I can trace it the straight line
back to me sitting here with you today
uh Shannon started with with my my dad
my parents my dad came over here he
graduated from IIT in India um and
wanted to come here to do his PhD he was
he was uh admitted to Purdue and he was
a civil engineer so he wanted to do his
PhD there he landed at uh uh at JFK with
$25 in his pocket and uh he asked the
first person first friendly face he saw
uh the quickest way to Lafia at Indiana
and um a kind gentleman put him on a
Greyhound bus uh and uh that was sort of
the start of my journey that's where I
was born as you said uh I grew up mostly
in the midwest uh in Michigan right
outside an arbor and um yeah Michigan
fans here um uh and uh you know pretty
normal childhood um you know I was we're
talking now I'm dating myself but this
was the early kind of 80s so it was like
a lot of Transformers and Star Wars and
that's what I and you know baseball
that's what I spent a lot of my my
childhood on but I remember uh
distinctly that uh there was really kind
of two Indian families in in our entire
town it was a small town in Michigan it
happened to be that the other kid Indian
kid was roughly my age his name happened
to be Neil also so that was a little
confusing for a lot of people um but um
as you alluded to in um right before
high school my folks decided to move
back to India and uh I did too and that
was um really at the time it felt like a
pretty big sort of traumatic change and
this is you know we're talking about the
mid 80s here so this is not like where
you can fly to India and back in a few
days and kind of it's just kind of
normal Power for the course that was a
big deal uh I couldn't speak the
language read it or write it I could
understand it cuz my parents would speak
it to each other occasionally but um
that was a big shock to the system and
um you know it was a seminal moment for
me because uh because of two things one
is it would just sort of um formulated
in my mind in retrospect sort of this um
concept of just really leaning into
change and that's been I think sort of a
theme throughout my career happens to be
really important in the tech business
which I'm in of course um but uh it was
really about sort of embracing that
change ultimately some of my best
friends through life are friends that I
met during High School uh in India I had
to learn you know nine years worth of
Hindi and Sanskrit and all of that uh um
and uh it's really about not just
surviving it's about thriving through
those types of uh kind of seminal sort
of pivotal moments and that's happened
For Better or Worse many many times in
my life and career since then but that
sort of like a big part of my childhood
of going from kind of this small
Midwestern town to this you know pretty
big city L now in in India and um just
being able to roll with it and and um
you know come out of it in a in a much
more sort of positive way well it sounds
like you embraced change again because
then you came back to the US to go to
Stanford for undergrad and then you came
back again to the GSB so how did those
experiences here at Stanford shape the
trajectory of your life uh oh boy well
you know I mean as you know uh John
alluded to in his his kind remarks I
mean Stanford is a real and as my wife
knows who's here uh heon knows is it's a
big it's a really important part of my
life because uh starting with undergrad
and then I'll get to the GSP in a second
it really it really did change my life
um even in high school I was kind of
like this um you know I knew that I
wanted to do something in technology you
know I remember I started this uh
software company when I was in high
school was uh and and uh it was like it
was true like nerd Nation Stanford was
like nerd upon nerd it was like
basically software to teach people
organic chemistry which is a very
strange thing but I loved chemistry and
I loved programming uh and I said they
did both of those things so I always
knew that I wanted to have a career
associated with Silicon Valley and uh
coming here as an undergrad was really
kind of the gateway to that but it was
really less about that engineering
education and really about everything
else that of course you all know that
Stanford offers
and um you know and so coming back for
the for for business school a because
it's you know the GSB let's face it but
also because I knew about Stanford uh
was a really easy decision um for me and
um you know what I'd say about about the
GSB and and you hopefully you all sort
of experienced this one thing that sort
of went into my decision there was the
fact that I felt like it was a school
that wasn't just going to be you know
business War Stories or what have you it
was really going to be
truly sort of grounded in fundamentals
and um that was my experience here and
I've always thought for years like why
is that sort of such a unique thing
about uh uh the GSB and um I was
actually in a meeting earlier this
morning and my friend uh Derek Bolton
like he always does kind of distilled it
down to its Essence and it's really
about sort of the teaching and faculty
model we have here that's this
combination of like the world's best
academics with the world's best you know
practitioners sort of coming together
and teaching and so I remember that as
sort of like a core part of my
experience here nobody talks about a lot
of the classroom experience when they
give their GSP story so I thought I
would I'd share that one because I just
remember distinctly every class that I
took you'd have this broad business
context but there would be like one or
two truly sort of seminal sort of
principal things that came out of that
class whether it was like my you know
non-m markets class and it was like this
concept of like you know the media and
voter theorem which you know many of us
know and it sounds like like kind of
this abstract dry thing but I can tell
you in my career like literally every
month there's a concept like that that
comes up where you apply those sort of
basic principles so that was sort of one
thing that um I remember distinctly from
my from my GSP days I learned about the
median voter theum in my class last qu
so yes will prove useful to you even
though it sounds very dry and
boring uh and so after the GSB you took
a risk and went back to this startup you
had been at double click which you
worked at and then eventually sold to
Google uh tell us about that experience
yeah so actually that that reminds me
like my the other GSB story of course
which you all uh are familiar with you
hear a lot about is you know the the
network of friends and relationships and
colleagues that you build both here uh
everybody in this Auditorium but also um
throughout your career and your life and
my experience was like literally like
kind of like a concentrated version of
that when I was making that decision to
go back to double click after business
school um because my my boss at double
click was a GSB
Alum uh my um the company had gotten
taken private which is the reason why I
went back to double click by Helman
Friedman which was the key investor of
it was Andy Ballard who's now my good
friend like 20 years later we're on the
advisory Council together um and uh my
future boss who was also trying to
recruit me the um because I was making a
choice between Google and double click
was my professor here ER Schmidt and so
it was basically like uh the GSB Alumni
network sort of like manifesting itself
in terms of my career choices at the mo
at that moment um but yeah as you point
out I did go back to double click it was
a it was a difficult choice I was
choosing between going to this you know
fast rising company called Google right
down the road here and um deciding to at
that time commute 3,000 miles in the
other direction back at double click
which was in New York and I had just uh
um convinced my wife who's a New Yorker
uh to move out to this like very
exciting town called palto from New York
City and then I I sprung the news that
hey um I might be taking this job back
at double click and commuting in either
direction but I did that um and I the
reason was because um it was really just
for me at least it was just kind of a
bet on myself it was it was definitely
uh much more of a startup environment it
was basically coming out of do 1.0 the
bubble had burst and it was it was a
pretty big sort of turnaround uh and so
there was an enormous amount of risk
with it uh in terms of business but I
just felt that um being given the
responsibility to kind of run um you
know a big part of it be the number two
at that company and really sort of
position it for what I thought would be
a very successful turn around and hope
you know fortunately it turned out that
way was just too good of an opportunity
to pass up and so that's why I chose to
go back to double click after business
school and double double click for those
who don't know is online advertising as
we know it today and I was talking to
your former professor and current
co-teacher George Foster who called you
the master negotiator and believes
that's the reason that Google acquired
double click in that moment uh can you
tell us what your approach is to
negotiating these deals you most
recently just landed NFL Sunday Ticket
for YouTube what advice do you have for
us as we're going on to do this in our
careers wow that's a great question um I
would say a few things so you so just by
way of background as you point out
double click was kind of is still kind
of this sort of operating system of the
internet economy at least as far as you
know the fact that it's powered through
advertising and so it was um this you
know very strategic conversation
obviously between double click and
Google and it's you know it's obviously
public information but there were lots
of other companies at the time that were
interested in our products and our
technology and and the company and um it
really just you know from a negotiation
standpoint it really just means um
I'm sure you hear this in your classes
but Jordan George and I have talked
about this over the years too it really
is about trying to find um unlocking
value on both sides and so yes it was a
steep price tag for Google you know
over3 billion but um it was really about
sort of showing what that strategic
opportunity was for um for Google in
this case and also then Google's all of
our partners our Publishers or what have
you and um it's it's really honestly not
about the back and forth and it's about
painting the picture that hopefully is
convincing enough that there's all this
value that can get unlocked if we can
come to um some kind of an agreement and
you know I think that I'd argue that in
terms of value for all of our partners
our Publishers or advertisers that use
that software on a regular basis that
that was proven true so you turned down
Eric Schmid but then ended up at Google
anyways and while you at Google you
became the chief product officer at
YouTube and fast forward to today you've
transitioned to CEO so what has your uh
trajectory at YouTube been like and what
has this transition to CEO been over
this last year well um well I've been at
Google a very long time you know over 15
years the first part of my career as I
was it was running our display and video
advertising uh business and and products
and um my my connection with YouTube
actually um predates both my time at
Google before we sold double click to
Google but also before YouTube uh became
part of Google so one of my biggest um
partners and customers when I was at
double click was this small company
above a pizza parlor in San Mato down
the road called YouTube and I remember
I'd visit from New York at the time and
I'd go in and I'd meet you know the
founders and the team and they would
just really be um uh um they the
conversation would be like Neil how can
you guys keep up like you can't keep up
with our growth like how are you going
to actually scale and it was just
amazing to see everything was always
sort of up and to the right at this you
know startup at the time called YouTube
and so I've I've been very closely
involved with that company even before
Google but during my time running ads at
Google uh the biggest uh advertising
property that we had at least in terms
of kind of non- search advertising was
YouTube so I'd work with them very
closely and then when I came over as
Chief product officer it was not just
you know working on the advertising side
but building all of our products for our
creators and our and our and our users
basically the products you use every day
and so that was kind of an easy decision
because I was so familiar with with
YouTube but um I took over um leading
YouTube about uh I guess now coming up
on nine months and that transition has
been uh interesting in a couple ways one
is that you know I've been at YouTube
for a very long time so obviously I'm
very familiar with our products and our
ecosystem uh but a big part of the job
is um uh different in the sense that now
I am sort of the face of obviously of
the company uh I have you know I spent a
lot of time with our creators as you saw
there um and so it's really about making
sure that this ecosystem that we're
bringing along of two billion users
million tens of millions of creators
obviously all of our partners our
advertisers and it's my job to really be
the steward of that and so that is that
sort of is what falls on my shoulders uh
and in a way that is um distinct because
ultimately the bck does stop with you so
these creators we've seen you at
Coachella you've mentioned them now what
have you learned from them you've spent
a lot of time with them over the last
year and presumably before that too what
have they taught you yeah I mean so um I
presumably lots of folks in this room
have you know their favorite creators
that they watch uh on our platform on a
regular basis I know many there are some
people in this audience who are creators
themselves and I would say uh a couple
of things um the first and probably the
most Salient thing and this is actually
advice I give to people who ask me like
what is the secret sauce of being a
successful Creator on the platform is it
really is just be true to yourself and
that is um sounds sort of very cliche
but I wish somebody had given me that
advice early in my career because
nothing Rings more true and I can tell
you for a fact that it's not the
algorithm it's all the other people that
are on the other side of that glass when
they're watching your video if you're a
creator that can tell instantaneously
whether that is actually truly your
authentic self or if you're trying to
basically put yourself in another person
shoes and what I always find striking is
you know whether it's you know it's erak
as you saw in that short or whether it's
Jimmy Donaldson Mr Beast or dude perfect
or whoever your favorite creators are
when you hang out with them in real life
they are pretty much exactly the way
that you experience them on the app and
that's their in in an Essence I think
that that's their secet secret to
success whether they're comic creators
whether they're Sports creators whether
they're musicians or artists like it
really is about that and of course
they're incredibly talented and know how
to tell stories but they're true uh to
themselves the other thing that I think
people don't recognize as much is that
not only are they amazing creative
people they are true entrepreneurs like
they build amazing businesses I was in
uh La last week I was meeting with um
you know some of our kind of OG creators
ret and Link um for those of you who may
be familiar they have this show every
day called uh good mythical morning I
see some head nods so you might be
familiar with it they obviously are
amazing creative types it's really them
coming true they're like they're like
childhood buddies grew up in uh I think
North Carolina um started a channel it's
been over a decade but they are
incredibly successful entrepreneurs they
have basically a Hollywood studio 100
people you know pre-production
production writers rooms um and they not
just don't just have their Channel
they're basically cultivating um you
know a number of other channels and
growing and they've made the choice to
build their careers on YouTube as
opposed to like what used to been the
case going and trying to find a gig with
you know an existing sort of traditional
Media Company yeah I think the creators
that you mentioned that are in our
classes here would probably really
resonate with that as being
entrepreneurs um and I also read
recently that onethird of kids now say
they want to be bloggers or YouTubers
specifically when they grow up this is a
changing growing industry how are you
viewing the future of the Creator
economy where is it headed um yeah I
mean we have uh we have one of those at
our house she's 11 years old and it's
not because her dad works there but she
we are convinced that that is like her
career path um yeah it's it's it's
pretty amazing I mean this term Creator
economy is obviously kind of a big
buzzword today but um it's really been
you know kind of the essence of YouTube
since the very beginning it is like
literally in our name YouTube it is
about building a presence on our
platform and our creators are looking to
do two things they're looking to build
an audience you know I I often describe
YouTube as the world's most efficient
you know connector of a creative person
with their audience no matter where they
are in the world and so that's the first
thing that we do as part of the Creator
economy the second thing is economy
ultimately it's about be finding a way
for these creators to earn a sustainable
living on our platform and so you know
we are you know the world's largest and
original sort of first Creator economy
we take enormous pride in that uh that's
what our creators tell us all the time
uh and when I use the term Creator I
don't I don't mean just sort of
YouTubers I mean everything from you
know the NFL and the NBA on one end of
the spectrum to you know somebody just
starting out in their garage today like
really that whole gamut um they're all
creators and so we have always um prided
ourselves that we we don't just find
your audience uh your fans we actually
help you generate um real businesses on
our platform whether that's through
advertising um you'll all know that we
have a number of subscription products
we have a number of products where fans
can directly fund uh creators and all of
that Revenue um uh from all of those
sources a big chunk of that acrs to our
creators and so I think in the last
three years we've paid out over $50
billion to this Creator economy
generated through all of these various
sort of business models that I talk
about and when you walk the halls of
YouTube that's a lot of what you hear
you hear a lot of that conversation
about what is the next thing that we
have to do to make creators creative
people on our platform successful no
matter where they are in the
world I imagine AI is a big part of this
content generation uh you just rolled
out several AI products uh at YouTube
and I'm curious what you think you're
most excited for about AI generated
content and what you're most concerned
about how will that affect these
creators you're talking about yeah um
you know there's again that's another
thing that I feel like there's just an
enormous amount of sort of Buzz about
that this year but first and foremost I
mean
YouTube a big part of our investment if
you think about what YouTube the company
is most of the people that work there
are software Engineers um lots of them
machine learning and AI software
engineers and when you open up the app
on your phones um what do you see you
see you see feed that is the product of
all of our investment in AI that ranking
that's happening that's basically
showing you the videos that you want to
watch right then and there is our
investment in machine learning and AI so
that has been a Bedrock of YouTube for a
long time but I do think that what you
what you said in terms of creation of
content that part I think is going to be
uh different and I and what I mean by
that is um you know AI is going to do a
couple of things one is it's going to
further democratize the creation of
amazing content I think in general that
is a very positive thing um but it's
also because it's going to do that like
it is just like any technology it can
fall in the hands of Bad actors uh and
just like we have to be that way with
any content on our platform we have to
be vigilant in terms of how we deal with
it so there's always that and I think
our philosophy My Philosophy is you have
to be really bold um you have to lean
into this techn techology back to this
you know theme of kind of leaning into
change uh because it will create these
capabilities that will be awesome for
all of us um but they but it also comes
with risk so instead in addition to bold
you have to be responsible and so that
means trying to anticipate uh risk
whether they're around misinformation or
other sort you know deep fakes whatever
you want to call it and so that's sort
of how we we think about these things
but you know just to give you a very
concrete example um the technology you
know we we talked about some of this in
the in the products you're alluding to
we just released this feature where you
know through a text prompt you can wish
for a video to be generated so you know
you have a creative concept um you know
dragons flying through Manhattan that
probably would have been hours if not
weeks worth of work if you are a Creator
prior to this type of Technology now
with this product called dream screen
you can do it just like that and so an
example of the power of this tool um and
so we have to really harness that and I
feel like YouTube uh the unique role
that YouTube plays um in this sphere is
that we really do sit at the Nexus of
technology and human creativity so our
our kind of Mantra is how do we harness
technology like AI to empower that human
creativity you have technology
creativity and then one of the other
things you just mentioned was safety and
responsibility and I think on a more
serious note my classmates and I and the
world have watched in horror as the
conflict in Israel and Gaza unfolded
these last few weeks what do you view as
YouTube's role on the world stage in
these moments as a source of information
and especially accurate
information yeah um first of all um you
know just like you said I mean we all at
YouTube me personally my family um were
just um shocked and just you know
incredibly deeply saddened by the
atrocities that unfolded on October 7th
and you know obviously the conflict
that's playing out on the ground
impacting millions of people on the
ground but also many people around the
world um and so you know the the the
reality is and I say this to my teams um
you know every day every week which is
uh what happens in the world happens on
YouTube it's a platform where two
billion people come to every single day
of course what's happening in the world
is manifesting itself on our platform
one of the strengths of YouTube is that
it is an open platform uh it is a
platform that has stood on Notions of
free speech in open platforms uh but one
of the things that I have learned um is
that um you can't have true truly an
open platform and true Free Speech if
you also don't have some rules of the
road and so from the very early days
YouTube has had Community guidelines uh
and um those Community guidelines are
the rules of the road of what we allow
on our platform what is removed from our
platform and the conflict in Israel and
Gaza that's playing out um is um a
reflection of those rules coming into
play so just to you know give you
concrete examples um you know obviously
there's horrific graphic violence um
often times in the form of video that
shows up on our platform we have clear
policies around that we try to strike
the balance between you know educational
and documentary news related content
that should stay up should get views as
people are looking for information on
our platform but we also try to make
sure that it is um not gratuitous that
it is appropriately ageg gated if it
needs to be we have policies against
violent extremism if the video is either
indirectly or directly um uh promoting
you know terrorist organizations like
Hamas then those get removed from our
platform and then to your point around
misinformation this is sort of the most
nebulous of course and the most diffuse
but um we try to um be extra vigilant
around that and the challenges you know
you just asked about Ai and I talked
about sort of deep fakes the real
problem oftentimes with mis
misinformation isn't uh isn't about deep
fakes it's about like really kind of
shallow sort of like just fakes
basically and so you a lot of the
misinformation narratives were
literally video clips of Call of Duty
like video games um that were basically
being being propagated as uh footage
from from the war and so just being
vigilant about those types of things
having clear policies having the
investment um uh in terms of not just
the policies but also you know in this
case again machine learning and AI to
actually detect content across a corpus
of billions and billions of videos is
investment that we have been working on
for years uh which we've been able to
put in place so that we can be fast
acting in terms of uh a crisis like this
um and then the other thing is as you
alluded to is making sure that we raise
up content so if you open up the app you
see that breaking news shelf which is
triggering I think still all over the
world um that has content that only
comes from channels that have built a
history of authority and credibility on
our platform and have earned the right
to actually show up in our news shelves
show up higher in our search rankings in
the in the in the algorithmic feeds Etc
so we use a combination of of techniques
and capabilities but also based on sort
of these core principles of open
platform but Community guidelines which
sound like competing principles but in
my mind they're actually
self-reinforcing this is such an
important topic right now so thank you
for giving us your Insight on it uh I
want to understand tactically some more
of your leadership style uh in this
situation and others I've heard you say
before that if a decision makes its way
up to your office it's a decision
between two hard choices because if it
was an easy one it would have already
been made so I imagine in situations
that like things don't fit within the
policies you just talked about um or
it's something you haven't prepared for
you have to make really hard choices as
a CEO now how are you doing that yeah
it's a it's a it's a great question it's
probably the one that I think about the
most um honestly Shannon and so I I will
just I'll tell you sort of the the
philosophy that works for me um and I'm
obviously doing it today as the leader
of YouTube but I think it applies
applies to any sort of leadership role
and I think that there are three things
um that are really important here and
conveniently they all start with P so
I'm going to I'm going to walk through
them the first is is people um I and I I
remember I think it might have been
actually at the business school where
somebody said to me um you know you can
as a CEO or as a leader you can find
somebody to do every single job except
for one which is hire the people to do
those jobs and so the one role that you
have first and foremost before anything
is actually finding the right people to
be on that bus before you drive to that
destination and so that's I prioritize
that in terms of my leadership team the
people who work directly for me at the
most senior levels of the company uh but
also you know levels below them and just
having a sort of rigorous rubric in
terms of the people that we bring into
our organization especially at the
leadership levels is like the first and
foremost back to your question of how to
do I actually execute it's really it
starts with people the second thing that
I would say and you know hopefully some
of this you got a flavor of this in my
my answer around the Israel Gaza uh
conflict the second p is principles and
I think this is really important and I
think hopefully my hope is actually at
the end of my career this is the thing
that is most Salient in terms of uh what
people perceive about how they work with
me is trying to be as principled as
possible in terms of the decisions that
you make and the reason why principles
are really important is because of what
you just said because by the time a
decision comes to you as a leader it's
often a trade-off between two bad
choices and if you're trying to make
that kind of a tradeoff you better have
some sort of Bedrock of principles by
which you're making those decisions and
so um you know as I I described sort of
one set of those sort of competing
principles the North Star is that we're
an open platform we stand for freedom of
speech but another principle which is
sort of self-reinforcing but competing
in some levels is you need to have some
rules of the road otherwise you can't
really have free speech if it's
everything goes so we have policies
against hate speech or harassment uh
they're defined very clearly and
narrowly but they're but they're sort of
like having that sort of principal
framework is important you can have
freedom of speech on our platform but it
doesn't mean that you get freedom of
reach that's another type of a principle
that then sort of permeates into your
into your product decisions and the
reason why the principles are so
important is because that's really what
permeates into decision- making at every
level of an organization not just for me
you know that happens at the you know VP
level and directors and managers and so
that's that's sort of the second thing
um and then the third thing which sounds
the most boring but actually would kind
of almost be the first chapter in any
book is um is actually around process
and uh I do think a lot about these
types of things because that's the
Cadence by which you run a company or an
organization um what is your um you know
how do you dial back everything from an
annual plan to a product road map to
quarterly okrs and goals to weekly
product reviews to weekly pipeline
reviews to daily standups having some
intentionality and sort of thoughts
around how you actually structure those
processes is actually kind of like the
lifeblood of a company that's what
that's what we do all day you know we
make you know a lot of my job is making
decisions with imperfect information
and you need to have that sort of
process architecture to do that so it's
people principles and process if I would
leave you with anything that's sort of
really what goes into kind of my
leadership Playbook we talk a lot about
principles and values here at the GSB um
and you mentioned a lot of the
organizational ones what are some of
your personal principles that drive you
where do those come from um it's a it's
a really interesting question I think
that um you know kind of i as I think
back on my um
uh I'll say a couple things about that
the first is um uh ever since I was a
kid um you know back to my days in
Michigan and you know my days in India
and kind of everything I I did feel
often times that I was part of the
community but I was also you know kind
of a bit of an outsider you know I in in
Michigan I was you know one of a handful
kids frankly that looked like me um you
know I had lots and lots of friends in
the community but I was a bit different
you know my family was different and so
that was a big part of um who I was
early childhood when I went to India I
was also again different like I was
around a lot of people that looked like
me but I kind of sounded like weird
right compared to compared to uh them
and so again it was sort of like being
part of the community but being sort of
an outsider and and for me um the thing
that sort of like where a lot of my
strength came from was Finding you know
those communities as an outsider through
a lot of the means that I used like
through through media actually so like
whether it was a book or a magazine or a
television show back in the day radio
kind of sports that was the means by
which I sort of found my community
that's why ultimately I am such a kind
of media junkie to this day and so
that's kind of a motivator for me and
actually if you think about even YouTube
like it's a place where you can go um
you know if you're like a 15-year-old
kid you feel like nobody understands you
you don't fit quite into the community
that you're in you can find your people
on a platform like YouTube again it's in
the name and so that's been like a big
motivator for me and it's sort of like
the thing one of the things that really
um gets me going in the morning the
other one that I'll just say um is uh
the one common thread sort of through my
career whether it was in my advertising
days or running YouTube is that
um probably one of the biggest changes I
lean leaned into was when I was
graduating from from undergrad which was
the dawn of the internet um and so again
that's obviously hard to imagine for
many people in this room but I remember
here at my dorm at Stanford like you'd
literally line up to get an email
address like it was like a whole crazy
thing like the internet was literally
organized in a directory right before
before before Google um and so that that
was um but kind of the core thing about
the internet is that it is free and
accessible and and YouTube is free and
accessible it's like you know kind of
the video representation of that uh and
the thing that really makes it that way
um is the only model the only business
model that actually allows for that is
an Advertising based one that's what
YouTube is that is what the internet is
and so the common sort of other
motivation for me is that we really do
feel like whether it's bringing all of
us our favorite creators or our favorite
news outlets or or what have you that is
actually powered through a lot of you
know the business models that my team
and and the like work on so in terms of
like again a motivator I feel like
that's a big deal and so and the story
that I always use to tell that is um the
just the recently the recently concluded
Olympics in Tokyo the kid who won or the
young man who won the um the gold medal
and the javelin uh was this you know was
this Indian kid you know India had never
won a medal you know kind of track and
field medal gold medal before then that
kid learned to throw the javelin on
YouTube and that's an amazing story um
like crazy that like he literally
learned and became the world's best
through watching videos on YouTube but
the reason I share that story Shannon is
the reason he could do that is because
YouTube was free and accessible to him
and the reason it was free and
accessible to him was because of all
this work that we do and this sort of
advertising powered uh business model so
I think I think it's really important
the power of community really is that
through line throughout your life and
career have you picked up any skills
like the javelin on YouTube what have
you picked up lately uh well actually
you know my the skills I pick up on it
are much much more uh mundane so uh
during uh during the
pandemic uh our um our garage door broke
down so uh I not only saved lots and
lots of time but some money by watching
you know a two-minute YouTube video and
uh I'm I'm I'm not a handyman as my wife
knows yes but I was able to fix it I
learned that on YouTube great uh before
we go to audience Q&A I'm going to ask
you a question we're asking all of our
speakers this year in ltin with our
theme of redefining tomorrow and you T
you've touched on a lot of this of what
the future will look like but as CEO of
YouTube If you could make one change
that would redefine tomorrow what would
it
be uh that's well I I would go back
actually a little bit to what what we
talked about um and it really is about
and again back on this sort of theme of
embracing change I do think and I've
been through really big sort of
generational technology shifts many of
them through my career as I said I
started uh my career really the dawn of
the internet so that was you know very
very pivotal and Salient the next big
one that happened of course was the move
to you know the supercomputers in our
pockets mobile phones and I would argue
that what we are in the midst of right
now this AI powered sort of revolution
is kind of that sort of third big
seminal almost sort of platform paradigm
shift and um from a YouTube standpoint I
my wish is that we again really lean
into it and embrace it there are lots of
challenges that we will be faced with
with this technology but on balance and
I'm an optimist uh what it's going to
unleash for all of us as human beings is
going to be uh truly profound and in the
the context of YouTube it's going to be
about creativity I gave you examples of
like dragons flying over New York you
can extrapolate that to a million
different types of creative use cases
but it's also going to be about you know
human empowerment that example that I
gave you around the javelin thrower well
what if you could go to a platform and
say you know give me you know a five
minute tutorial in physics 101 but do it
in the style of XYZ my favorite Creator
right like that is going to be the power
of this type of technology in our hands
and uh my world my wish is that we that
we lean into that great okay we're gonna
take some questions from the audience
all right let's do it hi Neil my name is
gray I'm a MBA 2 here thank you so much
for being here with us today I uh I'm
also a musician so I have a question
about the music industry um as we've
seen the rise of Digital streaming
platforms we've kind of been trained to
Value uh every song ever written for
about $10 a month and I wonder if you
have thoughts on where YouTube's unique
position in the music industry would
possibly be able to shift or scale that
so artists can get back to living off of
the art that they
create yeah uh you know the the music so
as you all know music is you know one of
the most important if not most you know
most important verticals on our on our
platform were one of the largest if not
largest sort of Music platforms out
there so it's core to what what YouTube
is and um I would say that the
distinction between YouTube and other
sort of you know products you might use
to listen to music is that um we are not
just about um creating uh opportunities
for musicians and artists through the
consumption of their you know in this
case not to use too much like industry
jargon but your primary you know music
art track or what have you we are a
platform that is that takes music and
mixes it in with other Creator content
you know user generated content that is
the foundation of of the of this other
pie that we've been able to grow for the
music industry that is beyond just
streaming revenues so the fact that if
you watch a video it's a wedding video
on YouTube it's got a a track from uh
Drake that money from that video through
advertising or subscriptions actually
acrs to the musician or artist and so
it's a system called Content ID uh it is
proprietary you know YouTube technology
but I think it's sort of one of the
crown jewels of what YouTube is and so
our goal is to continue to try to really
expand more of that pool we we are one
of the unique Platforms in that you can
generate money through subscription
revenues on our platform that acre to
the music business but also through
advertising the complexity sort of that
goes into it without getting into too
much detail is that there are lots of
players obviously that own various parts
of Rights uh in the music industry so
there's obviously uh uh um publishing
companies there's record labels as you
know and so it's really about sort of
the economic pie and sort of how it gets
divided up but our goal at YouTube um is
to try to grow That Pie as much as
possible and actually that's how we
think about new technologies like
generative AI how does it actually
create new opportunities for artists at
the end of the day we're in the business
of artists and creators so our goal
ultimately is to make sure that what we
do is ACR to our art artist and we have
to do that obviously with our partners
like the labels or Publishers but that's
that's a bit how we think about it which
is ultimately growing the pie through
these various revenue streams that we
have NE uh I'm shat and I'm an MBA one
student here was curious to know if
there was any particular product or
feature in YouTube that you very
passionate about but it didn't take off
in the way that you wanted it to or it
didn't reach the potential that you were
looking for it uh there's many products
that we um there our culture is one of
of experimentation we really do try to
try out new things um we used to have a
product um in a in a number of our um
kind of we call them sort of our next
user Emerging Markets it used to be
called YouTube go it was basically kind
of a lightweight version of YouTube that
we built for
um uh less capable Android phones in a
lot of Emerging Markets it turned out uh
that that wasn't necessary because what
ended up happening in a lot of these
markets is uh Lea frogs basically the
local Loops the data Loops um in India
is a great example where Reliance just
invested extremely heavily and made it
so that that problem of data and the
bits of video kind of went away so
that's an example of a product uh that
we tried out didn't work and then we we
Sunset it um appropriately in that case
another one that was a lot more
controversial that some of you may
remember uh is um is uh dislike counts
on our on our it's like it's like
literally I still to this day get tweets
and emails about this feature that we
that we turn down which was eliminating
the count on dislikes as many of you
obviously clearly know it was a very
controversial decision but we uh but we
made that choice to turn down that
feature and again it actually and that
one actually goes back to this
principles point that I was making which
is we have an ecosystem of creators and
viewers and um they are both incredibly
important to us
but um how do we make a decision when it
comes to a trade-off between those and
the trade-off in this case was viewers
really in many cases maybe wanted to see
those view counts or those dislike
counts as an indication of like the
quality of the video or what have you
but what was happening was that count
became an incentive for you know kind of
harassment brigading and things like
that that disproportionately impacted a
class of our creators and particularly
vulnerable creators on our platform
female creators uh and the like and that
was an example again of sort of the
principle was that well our viewers come
to our platform for the thriving Creator
ecosystem so we better really get that
right um even though it might lead to a
short-term trade-off on the viewer side
because in the end what's good for our
creators is going to be good for our
viewers so that's another example of a
feature that we that we turn
down hey Neil my name is Devin I'm mba1
here at the GSB you I think as we all
know learning has been such a huge part
of YouTube since its Inception and you
kind of hinted at maybe going from a
more passive to an active role in
promoting learning on the platform could
you tell us if that is in the strategy
and what that might look like uh I can
tell you a little bit um uh so you I so
you're right learning is a is a huge use
case on our platform I think the latest
sort of I think it was a Pew study that
I saw you especially for real you know
young people teens um you 95% of them
use YouTube on a regular basis the
biggest use case of course is is is is
learning on our um and um so we and you
know it's interesting you know YouTube
kind of grew around this learning use
case almost kind of like despite
ourselves right like it's not like we
built a particular set of features
around it but recently you know one of
my priorities has been investing in this
especially from kind of the learner
standpoint but also importantly from the
the teacher educator standpoint because
there needs to be a business model that
works for them there and what's
interesting about the learning vertical
because sometimes learning because it
end oftentimes ends up being very
specific or Niche you an ad supported
model because ads require scale doesn't
necessarily always always work and so
one of the products we've been working
on is something called YouTube courses
so that you can actually bundle a
playlist of videos and actually allow
the creators to put them in the order
that they want want to have some
additional features in terms of
interactivity and things like that so
that's an example of something that
we're doing we're also thinking about
should we experiment with um being able
to generate quizzes off of videos so
that if you're a learner you know you're
you know you're what an eighth grader
watching an algebra one video can you um
check to see if you actually got the key
Concepts out of it things like that so
that's sort of the general sort of realm
in terms of how we think about it but I
agree with you that obviously Learning
Happens not just by watching it happens
through interactivity we're obviously
we're fundamentally a platform about
consuming video and audio content so
we're never going to build you know all
that functionality that you require but
we can augment it uh we can basically
provide we can make it so that we
provide the better tools that then fit
into perhaps another education tool or
if you're a self- learner organize them
in a way that's productive for you and
so that's that's sort of how we think
about that hi Neil thank you so much for
being here my name is Andrew and I'm an
NBA 1 my question is around Sports and
so following the acquisition of Sunday
Ticket and the NBA media rights are
coming up for auction in a little bit
curious to hear how Sports and live
sports streaming fits into YouTube's
overall strategy and business model yeah
um so the way that I think about sports
is so first of all you know we're we're
again back to what I was saying about
music probably applies in the realm of
sports too you know we're probably one
of the largest Sports Platforms in the
world and you know I grew up watching
when I was in undergrad here I would
just I'd watch like 5 hours of sports
center in a row just on in the
background right like that's because I'm
a I'm a sports not myself but then I
look at it through the lens of my son
who's 15 he's as big of a sports fan as
I am his his version of consuming
highlights is on YouTube often times
through the lens of his favorite YouTube
creators Sports creators in what we call
long form so you know traditional VOD
content on YouTube but also through
YouTube shorts uh and so the world of
consumption of sports content is
changing dramatically um that's the
expectation especially for young people
and so the sports industry has had to
adapt to that that's why you see lots of
content moving to streaming platforms uh
and that was sort of the backdrop of
things like uh uh Sunday ticket to the
NFL's credit they recognize that their
fans particularly their younger fans are
on YouTube and that's where they would
prefer to consume a lot of this content
and so for us um it was really about
super serving those sports fans that are
already on our platform so it's about
kind of I think three things in that
case it's about choice right like now if
you're a football fan you don't need to
call somebody up and have somebody come
out and install a dish on your house
right like you just two Taps and you're
watching your favorite games the second
is around just what YouTube and Google
do which is just Technical and product
Innovation right so that experience
glass to glass from the truck on the
field to your television screen has to
be best in class so that's where you
know features like multiv view if you
guys have played around it come into
play right like I see some head nods for
I can tell the sports fans in the
audience so that's that's like product
Innovation that we should bring but the
third thing that I think is sort of the
most interesting here and back to kind
of my son's example are this blending of
Worlds like YouTube creators right like
the fact that even for sports bringing
that to the table is the expectation
that their young fans have so you know
some of you may have seen right like Mr
Beast was at the Tampa Bay game this
weekend right like that kind of a thing
is just kind of natural if you are a
young sports fan and so really leaning
into that type of change uh is another
important aspect of it so we think about
it you know really holistic consumer
Choice product Innovation kind of broad
sort of content integration and that's
and if we super serve those sports fans
um not only does that sort of acre to
them but it sort of spills over into the
rest of the ecosystem there's obviously
a direct svod subscription opportunity
there but it also spills over into our
advertising
business great thank you so much for
answering these questions we are going
to end with a view from the top
tradition of Rapid Fire uh I will say a
sentence and you will complete it are
you ready
all right let's do
it first one if I had a personal YouTube
channel the content would be about oh
for me that's easy it'd be about
something sports related like I wouldn't
be the best commentator but it would be
maybe something to do with the Warriors
yeah great we love the Warriors around
here uh the biggest similarity between
Indiana and India is probably probably
the the those five letters in the name
is probably would
say yeah yeah my favorite thing to do
when I'm not working
is uh hanging out with my with my family
our kids is probably what I like to do I
always I always say that you know in my
job I have to travel a lot I have
obviously lots of meetings I get to you
know meet lots and lots of incredible
people but like my favorite thing to do
on the weekends is just hang around the
house with my kids
honestly a piece of advice would give my
younger self
is uh I I'll go back to what I said I
mean I I I wish somebody has given me
this advice when I was you know first
coming out of business school is just
truly be uh true to yourself like really
try to again it sounds cliched but
really think hard about setting your own
course think about it in terms of longer
term like not I'm not saying over plan
but just try to really really answer the
question about like on the margin how is
this going to be truly about what I want
as opposed to what other people's
expectations are of me and we'll bring
it full circle my favorite moment at
Coachella
was uh I don't know what do you what
would it be well uh it was uh let's see
Bad Bunny was great great answer my
wife's favorite moment was bad bun great
answer Neil thank you so much this has
been
great thank you thank
you